hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kitchen I
thought we weren't gonna do the intro
that's true yeah yeah yeah let's try
again yeah okay hello and welcome to
trigonometry we can't use that so you
can understand the unprofessionalism
that I deal with on a day-to-day hello
and welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance in kissing and
listen guys we just wanted to put out
this very short clip to say a few things
first of all we've just reached 15,000
subscribers in a very short period of
time so thank you all for subscribing
for following for retweeting for sharing
our stuff he's been absolutely brilliant
the other thing we wanted to talk to you
about as well as obviously there's been
this big controversy with patreon a
couple of months ago where a patron band
saga off the platform who's one of our
former guests and you know that was a
big that was a big issue for us right
yeah it was a big issue we did have to
consider our position very very much and
in the end we decided to stay with
patron no here's the thing guys right we
totally understand if you've stopped
using patron because in I for example
was supporting many shows on patron
myself I stopped using the platform and
I totally get where you're coming from
but the problem is that we are trying to
do free speech on the show right we're
trying to have these conversations that
we're trying to contribute to the debate
and if you've moved off patreon
essentially what's happened with us is
we are losing a lot of money by the fact
that people have stopped using the
platform so what we wanted to ask you to
do if you don't want to use patron which
we totally understand right please
there's a PayPal link that we have at
the bottom of every video which you can
use to give us a recurring monthly
donation which will do exactly the same
thing and we get all of that money as
well so if you really believe in what
we're doing and you want to keep us in
cocaine do you take cocaine I'm half
Latin America if you want to keep us
supporting us with what we're doing then
please support us via PayPal that will
make a very big difference to us or if
you're happy with patron we've still got
the reward you can get a trigonometry
mug you can get other thing
we're going to be doing lots of live
events coming up and again that's
something that if you're a patron that
will help and finally one of the things
we've also started doing as you may have
noticed is we're putting out short
preview clips of the episodes and if you
want early access to those they're only
available on patrons so if you're happy
with that please do that if not support
us on PayPal it really means that we can
keep the show going because it is
expensive we spend hundreds of pounds
every month putting the episodes out
there for your enjoyment absolutely and
if you were one of those people who
can't afford to contribute we know you
know you may be a student on employee
whatever I speak you still enjoy so
number one thank you so much and number
two just tell people about it tell
people spread the hate let's make the
alright surge across the galaxy
Frances you realize we're not all right
you [ __ ] all right that wonderfully
upbeat no thank you so much for continue
to support and share and talk about it
and we'll see you soon with some more
incredible guests in episodes see you
later guys take her